Hey Smarties, it's Sean Hayes here. You may remember that we launched a new bite-sized game show last year called Clueless. In every episode, our hilarious host, Elliot Cailin, takes me and a friend of mine through a different game and sometimes they're word puzzles or chains of common phrases or robots singing songs, we have to guess. It's a whole lot of fun. Here's an episode that came out today with my good friend, actor and comedian, Jeff Max, where we play one of our favorite new games, Word Workout.
嘿，Smarties，我是肖恩·海斯。大家可能还记得，我们去年推出了一档名为《Clueless》的全新精简版游戏节目。在每一期节目中，我们搞笑的主持人埃利奥特·凯林会带着我和我的朋友玩不同的游戏，有时是文字谜题、常用短语接龙，有时是机器人唱歌，我们得去猜。这真的非常有趣。今天有一期节目上线了，嘉宾是我的好朋友、演员兼喜剧演员杰夫·马克斯，我们在节目中玩了我们最喜欢的新游戏之一：Word Workout。
Check out Smartless Presents Clueless Anywhere. You get your podcast's new episodes every Monday and Thursday. I'd like to open this episode with a quick financial update. Due to inflation, a bird in the hand is now worth four in the bush please adjust your proverbs accordingly this is Clueless I'm Clueless! Welcome to SmartList presents Clueless the only puzzle podcast period I refuse to recognize any others. I'm your host, Elliot Kalin, and I come from the future with a warning for all mankind. But first, please welcome the man
欢迎收听《SmartLess Presents: Clueless Anywhere》。每周一和周四，你都可以收听播客的新剧集。我想在这期节目的开头做一个简短的财务更新。由于通货膨胀，手里的一只鸟现在相当于灌木丛里的四只了——请相应地调整你们的谚语。这里是《Clueless》，我是一无所知（Clueless）！欢迎收听《SmartLess Presents: Clueless》，这是绝无仅有的纯正解谜播客，我拒绝承认有任何其他同类节目。我是你们的主持人埃利奥特·凯林，我从未来带着对全人类的警告而来。但首先，请欢迎这位
who's got entertainment in his blood, but don't worry, he's taking something for it. Sean Hayes, thanks for being here, Sean. Yeah, I can't get off it. That's the problem. Today, we are joined by an old friend of mine. His name is Jeff Max. We grew up in the theater together.
血液里流淌着娱乐精神的男士——不过别担心，他已经在为此接受治疗了。肖恩·海斯，谢谢你能来，肖恩。是的，我戒不掉。这就是问题所在。今天，和我们一起作客的是我的一位老朋友。他叫杰夫·马克斯。我们是一起在剧场里长大的。
If you heard the previous episode, you would know what I'm talking about. He needs a little slapping around sometimes because we gotta keep him real. Ladies and gentlemen, it's Jeff or Jeffrey, depending on how gay he is that day, Max. Hello! And he's got, sing a little something for us.
如果你听过上一集，你就会知道我在说什么。有时候真得狠狠扇他两巴掌才行，因为我们得让他认清现实。女士们先生们，这位是杰夫——或者叫杰弗里，取决于他那天有多“弯”——马克斯。大家好！他准备了，给我们唱一小段。
I'll help me with the headlifters and ball barrels. That's it. All right. Wow. That's it. That was a very little something. They say patience is a virtue, but having too much patience is just being lazy. So let's stop waiting around and reveal the answer to last episode's cliffhanger puzzle,
我来帮我处理一下高音和低音。就是这样。好吧。哇。就这样。这真的是非常“一小段”。人们都说耐心是一种美德，但耐心过头就是懒惰了。所以我们别再干等了，来揭晓上一集悬念谜题的答案吧，
shall we? Yeah. You may remember it was an odd one out that went thusly. Which word does not belong? Drove? Never? Murder? School? Or unkindness? I mean, well, the first thing, Jeff, I was thinking was there's a like a group of crows can be a murder, a group of fish can be a school. Oh! But am I on the right track? You are very much on the right track, yes. Because you have a drove of something.
好吗？好。大家可能还记得，那是一个“找不同”的题目，内容如下：哪个词不属于同一类？Drove（车队/驱赶）、Never（从不）、Murder（乌鸦群/谋杀）、School（鱼群/学校）或者Unkindness（渡鸦群/不友善）？我的意思是，嗯，第一件事，杰夫，我在想，有一群乌鸦可以叫 murder，一群鱼可以叫 school。哦！那我走对方向了吗？你非常走对方向了，是的。因为你有一 drove 的……某种东西。
You do have a drove of something. But an unkindness, I don't know what that is. And a never, I don't know like a group of animals that's a never. Yeah, you're right. But I don't know a group of animals that's an unkindness. I mean, that's weird. But that does sound like one.
你确实有一 drove 的某种东西。但 unkindness，我不知道那是什么。还有 never，我不知道——就像某种动物群叫 never。对，你说得对。但我不知道有什么动物群叫 unkindness。我的意思是，这很奇怪。但听起来确实像那么回事。
I'm going to say never. I'm just going to go for it. You're exactly right, Sean. Here's what I love about what you did. This is classic professional puzzle playing. You're like, I have a sense of it. I know what some of these things are. I'm narrowing in.
我要选 never。我直接豁出去了。你完全猜对了，肖恩。这就是我最喜欢你的地方。这是经典的职业级解谜玩法。你会说：“我有点感觉了。我知道其中一些是什么。我在缩小范围。”
I'm getting closer. I'm using my logic to narrow it down to two. And then at the last two, you're like, I don't know which one, so I'm gonna take a gamble. Because every game player at heart is a gambler. You're exactly right. How about that? I would have never known there's a group
“我越来越近了。我用逻辑把范围缩小到两个。”然后在最后两个时，你会说：“我不知道是哪个，所以我要赌一把。”因为每个游戏玩家内心深处都是个赌徒。你完全说对了。怎么样？我以前从来不知道有一群
of animals called a murder. I've never heard of that. Oh yeah, murder of crows. A murder of crows? And it's an unkindness of ravens. Really? Is that really? Really.
动物被称为 murder。我从来没听说过。哦，对，a murder of crows（一群乌鸦）。A murder of crows？还有 a unkindness of ravens（一群渡鸦）。真的吗？真的吗？真的。
By the way, just so you know, and everybody who works on this show, Jeff's signature is, Oh, really? Oh, really? Really. What's a drove? A drove of donkeys. Donkeys come in droves.
顺便说一句，你们要知道，所有在这个节目工作的人都知道，杰夫的标志性口头禅就是：“哦，真的吗？”“哦，真的吗？”“真的。”什么是 drove？A drove of donkeys（一群驴）。驴总是成群结队（droves）。
Okay, murders of crows, droves is donkey, schools is fish, unkindness is ravens, which is very close to crows's, and Never is nothing. Yeah, and Oh Really of Jeff's, I guess is the- Oh Really of Jeff's. Really!
好吧，murders 是乌鸦群，droves 是驴，schools 是鱼，unkindness 是渡鸦群（这和乌鸦群很接近），Never 是什么都不是。对，至于杰夫的“哦真的吗”，我猜那是——杰夫的“哦真的吗”。真的！
This is what I'm missing, is we've never had a guest with a catchphrase before, and I'm very excited about that. Yeah, yeah, and by the way, a catchphrase that caught on in literally 10 seconds. Well, you also have to follow it up with, I never knew. Also get a couple of drinks in them and that oh really
这就是我一直觉得缺少的，我们以前从没邀请过自带口头禅的嘉宾，我对此感到非常兴奋。对，对，顺便说一句，这个口头禅在短短literally 10秒钟内就流行开了。嗯，你还得接着说一句：“我从来不知道。”另外，只要让他们喝几杯，那个“哦真的吗”就会
is about two octaves higher and about 20 decibels louder. What, drinks? Yeah. Thank you to Monopoly for supporting today's episode. Clueless listeners, Monopoly has created three new ways to play with expansions you add on to your classic Monopoly set. If you want to own the whole board, the buy everything expansion lets you do just that. That's right, every space on the board is up for grabs.
高出大约两个八度，音量大出大约20分贝。什么，喝酒？对。感谢 Monopoly 对今天节目的赞助。Clueless 的听众们，Monopoly 推出了三种全新的游戏玩法，通过将扩展包添加到你的经典大富翁套装中。如果你想拥有整个棋盘，“买下一切”扩展包就能让你如愿以偿。没错，棋盘上的每一个格子都可以抢购。
Go to jail, buy it. Free parking, yep that too. And with the buy die, you get even more ways to win fast. If you're the kind of person who likes to press their luck, like Elliot, the free parking jackpot expansion is your jam. Land on free parking, spin the wheel, and boom, cash in big. But don't get too comfortable because it's risky. One spin could have you rolling in money or losing it all.
进监狱？买下它。免费停车？对，那个也可以。通过“购买骰子”，你可以获得更多快速获胜的方法。如果你是那种喜欢碰运气的人，比如埃利奥特，“免费停车大奖”扩展包就是你的菜。停在免费停车格上，转动转盘，轰，大笔现金到手。但别高兴得太早，因为这充满风险。转一下可能让你腰缠万贯，也可能让你一无所有。
It's high stakes, fast, and definitely for the competitive players. And if you're a mastermind who loves a little chaos, like Sean, the Go to Jail expansion is a game changer. Jail isn't a punishment. It's strategic. Bribes, steal, and collect corruption cards to mess with your opponents. Turns out crime does pay, at least in Monopoly.
这风险极高、节奏明快，绝对适合好胜心强的玩家。如果你是个喜欢制造一点混乱的大师级玩家，比如肖恩，“进监狱”扩展包将彻底改变游戏规则。进监狱不再是惩罚，而是一种策略。行贿、偷窃、收集腐败卡来坑你的对手。事实证明，犯罪确实有回报，至少在大富翁里是这样。
So whether you're a risk taker, rule breaker, or money maker, Monopoly has three new expansion packs for you to explore. Pick your pack or grab all three and let the game get a whole lot more exciting. Available now on Amazon. All is fair in Monopoly expansions. Monopoly is a trademark of Hasbro. Listeners at home, did you get the answer? If not, that's okay. Postmodern theory tells us all truth is relative. But let's pretend there's such a thing as objective reality for just a couple more minutes so we can play today's main game and it's called Word Workout.
所以，无论你是冒险者、破局者还是捞钱好手，Monopoly 都有三款全新的扩展包供你探索。挑选你的扩展包，或者把三个全买下，让游戏变得更加刺激。现已在亚马逊上架。在大富翁扩展包里，一切皆有可能。Monopoly 是孩之宝的注册商标。家里的听众们，你们猜出答案了吗？如果没有，也没关系。后现代主义理论告诉我们，所有的真理都是相对的。但让我们再假装存在客观现实几分钟，这样我们就能玩今天的主打游戏了，它叫 Word Workout（文字健身）。
Yeah. Word Workout, we're working on Word Sound. Work, work out, no need no key. Like for sure. Good, it's really good. Isn't that good? Yeah, it's really good. These are great songs. I can't wait for the album to come out.
对。Word Workout，我们在锻炼文字之声。Workout，workout，不需要钥匙（no key）。就像是一定的。好，真的很好。不是很棒吗？对，真的很棒。这些都是好歌。我等不及这张专辑发行了。
Now, okay, we've got seven words for you. Each of them wants to slim down and lose some weight, and we're gonna help get them into shape. For each clue, I'm gonna give you the starting word, and then ask you to remove one letter, and then rearrange the remaining letters to create a new spelt word. I love this, I love this, I love this.
好了，接下来我们准备了七个单词。它们每个都想减减肥、瘦瘦身，我们要帮它们恢复体形。对于每个线索，我会给你一个起始词，然后让你去掉一个字母，再重新排列剩下的字母，创造出一个拼写正确的新单词。我太喜欢了，我太喜欢了，我太喜欢了。
Let's have an example. If the clue was remove a letter from cinema to get a type of Japanese animation, what would you do? Anime. Yep, exactly. You take out the C, rearrange them, you get anime. Are you ready to send these words to the gym? Sure. Yeah.
我们来举个例子。如果线索是：从 cinema（电影院）中去掉一个字母，得到一种日本动画，你会怎么做？Anime（动漫）。对，完全正确。你去掉 C，重新排列，就得到了 anime。你们准备好把这些单词送去健身房了吗？当然。对。
Excellent. Word workout. Let's start with question number one. Remove a letter from candle to get a series of rhythmic movements. Rhythmic? Movements. Dance. Yes, very good. Damn, I would have never gotten that. Tell me, which letter did you remove out of there? I remove, well, if you speak the English language, I remove the letter L. Oh. Question number two. Remove a letter from basket to get a prime cut. Oh, I was going to say brisket.
太棒了。Word Workout。我们从第一题开始。从 candle（蜡烛）中去掉一个字母，得到一系列有节奏的动作。有节奏的？动作。Dance（舞蹈）。是的，非常好。天哪，我永远也猜不到。告诉我，你从里面去掉了哪个字母？我去掉的——如果你说英语的话，我去掉的是字母 L。哦。第二题。从 basket（篮子）中去掉一个字母，得到一块优质肉排。哦，我本来想说 brisket（牛胸肉）。
Yeah. To get a prime cut. Take a look at those letters and see which ones you might be able to rearrange to me. Steak! Oh, you got it. Yes, steak. You take out the B, which is the part of the cow you don't use anyway, and you just get the steak.
对。得到一块优质肉排。看一看那些字母，看看你能把它们重新排列成什么。Steak（牛排）！哦，你答对了。是的，steak。你去掉 B——反正那是牛身上用不到的部分——然后你就得到了 steak。
Wow, that's good. You know, I'm going to go ahead and put the L from candle in steak. No, I'm kidding. And get Steelek. Get Steelek. Question number three. Remove a letter from course spelled C-O-A-R-S-E. So course is in rough.
哇，真厉害。你知道吗，我要把 candle 里的那个 L 放进 steak 里。不，我开玩笑的。然后变成 Steelek。变成 Steelek。第三题。从 course（拼写作 C-O-A-R-S-E）中去掉一个字母。这里的 course 是指“粗糙的”。
Remove a letter from course to get the sports results. To get the sports results? Score! Yes, very good. You remove the A and you get score. Number four. Remove a letter from serial, as in things in order, S-E-R-I-A-L, to get some long tracks. Long tracks. Mm-hmm. Long tracks. Long tracks. Long tracks. Long tracks. Long tracks.
从 course 中去掉一个字母，得到体育比分。得到体育比分？Score（比分）！是的，非常好。你去掉 A，就得到了 score。第四题。从 serial（意为按顺序排列的事物，拼写作 S-E-R-I-A-L）中去掉一个字母，得到一些长轨道。长轨道。嗯哼。长轨道。长轨道。长轨道。长轨道。长轨道。
I was hoping you would also say long tracks, Jack. So we would all say it. Rails. Yes, rails, exactly. You remove the E and you get Rails. Damn Sean, you're kicking my... Come on. You got score. Right? I think I said that with you. Yeah. Question number five, remove a letter from barber to get a kind of fitness
我本希望你也说长轨道，杰克。这样我们大家就都会说了。Rails（铁轨）。是的，rails，完全正确。你去掉 E，就得到了 rails。该死，肖恩，你把我……得了吧。你猜到了 score，对吧？我想我是跟你一起说出来的。对。第五题，从 barber（理发师）中去掉一个字母，得到一种健身
activity. Remove a letter from barber to get a kind of fitness activity. Huh? Barber. B-A-R-B-A-R, right? Or is it E-R? E-R. B-A-R-B-E-R, yeah. Barber. Not the elephant? Barber the elephant is a different story.
活动。从 barber 中去掉一个字母，得到一种健身活动。哈？Barber。B-A-R-B-A-R，对吗？还是 E-R？E-R。B-A-R-B-E-R，对。Barber。不是那头大象？大象巴巴（Babar）是另一回事。
He holds the scissors in his trunk. It's pretty cute. Wait. Ab? No. Would you like a hint or a clue? Sure. A hint.
它用鼻子拿着剪刀。挺可爱的。等等。Ab？不。你想听个提示或线索吗？好啊。一个提示。
Okay. The hint is this is a ballet-based fitness activity. That's the hint. If you want a clue, I'll tell you what letter to remove. Oh. It's a ballet-related activity. A ballet-based fitness activity. Bar. Yes, bar. Exactly right. B-A-R-E. Yes, you removed the B to get bar. That was good. But that's a hard one, right?
好的。提示是，这是一种基于芭蕾舞的健身活动。这就是提示。如果你想要线索，我告诉你去掉哪个字母。哦。这是一种与芭蕾相关的活动。一种基于芭蕾的健身活动。Bar（芭蕾把杆）。是的，bar。完全正确。B-A-R-R-E（注：题目此处语境为把杆训练 barre）。是的，你去掉 B 就得到了 bar。这太棒了。但这很难对吧？
That was a really hard one. I hope you walk away from this knowing that you got a really hard one and it just gives you confidence for whatever you're doing next. Yeah. Wait, a fitness what? Activity. So what do you do there? You just hang out on the bar. The bar. No, when you do bar, you do like a bunch of- But I, but I would think it's more dance related and that, I don't know
这真的很难。我希望你离开这里时知道，你答对了一个非常难的题目，这会为你接下来要做的事增添信心。等等。健身什么？活动。那你去那里做什么？你就挂在把杆上。把杆。不，当你做 barre 练习时，你会做一堆——但是，我，但我会觉得这跟舞蹈更相关，我不知道
anybody that goes to the gym and rushes to the bar. Does bar. Does bar. Well, they do. Well, they have, it's a, they've, they've started to, it's a, you know, they can turn anything into fitness. They turn ballet, exercise into fitness. Oh, is that new? Okay, great. Just like how Pilates used to be just plates. Right.
有谁会去健身房然后冲向把杆的。做 barre。做 barre。呃，他们会的。呃，他们有，这是一个，他们已经开始，你知道的，他们可以把任何东西变成健身。他们把芭蕾、运动变成健身。哦，这是新事物吗？好吧，太棒了。就像普拉提过去只是盘子（plates）一样。对。
Yes. Right, very good. Sure. Question number six, remove a letter from a ringer to get the span of a monarchy Move a letter from ring rain rain. Yes rain. Very good And now finally our last one for this game remove a letter from the sellout to get away to mess up someone's hair Tussle yes Very good. That was good.
是的。对，非常棒。当然。第六题，从 ringer（敲钟人/响铃者）中去掉一个字母，得到一个君主统治的时期。去掉一个字母，ring，rain，rain。是的，rain（统治/雨，注：reign 同音）。非常好。现在终于到了我们这个游戏的最后一题：从 sellout（卖光/叛徒）中去掉一个字母，把一个人的头发弄乱的方法。Tussle（弄乱/争斗）。是的，非常好。这很棒。
I thought that was going to be the hardest of them. But instead, if anything, it was the easiest of them. How about that? No pain, no gain. Excellent work. But now that we've sweated off all those unsightly extra letters, we've got to find some way to dispose of them. How about we recycle them as today's
我以为这会是最难的一个。但相反，如果说有什么不同的话，它反而是最简单的。怎么样？没有付出就没有收获（No pain, no gain）。干得漂亮。但既然我们已经通过运动甩掉了所有那些碍眼的多余字母，我们就得想个法子处理它们。把它们回收利用作为今天的
Mega Clue. Mega Clue Question. To today's Mega Clue? Mega Clue Question. To solve the Mega Clue, I want you to take the letters you removed from those words, and I'll remind you what they are, and I want you to rearrange them to reveal a piece of workout equipment you could buy a drink from. And the letters are L, B, A, E, B, R, and L. And what's the clue? And the clue is a piece of- Barbell. Well, you don't even get the clue anymore.
Mega Clue（超级线索）怎么样？超级线索问题。今天的超级线索？超级线索问题。要解开超级线索，我需要你把从那些单词里去掉的字母拿出来——我来提醒你们都有哪些字母——然后把它们重新排列，揭示出一件你可以从上面买到饮料的健身器材。这些字母是：L、B、A、E、B、R 和 L。线索是什么？线索是一件——Barbell（杠铃）。好吧，你甚至不需要线索了。
It's too late. That's the right answer. Yay! It was a piece of workout equipment you could buy a drink from, and the answer was barbell. And it's not a bar again, B-A-R-R-E? No, this time it's just another kind of bar. Let's not lose our pleasing disposition.
太迟了。那是正确的答案。耶！这是一件你可以从上面买到饮料的健身器材，答案就是 barbell（杠铃，谐音 bar-bell，把杆/酒吧-铃）。这又不是 bar，B-A-R-R-E？不对，这次只是另一种 bar（酒吧/把杆）。我们可别破坏了愉快的心情。
And it's not an elephant. It's not a French elephant. Yay! We've narrowed it down. Babar. Nice work. Great work, guys. Well, listeners, did you do as well as Sean and Jeff? If so,
而且它不是一头大象。它不是一头法国大象。耶！我们缩小范围了。Babar（巴巴，大象名）。干得漂亮。小伙子们，干得漂亮。好了，听众朋友们，你们的表现和肖恩、杰夫一样好吗？如果是这样的话，
your steak is free! But before you chow down, make sure you keep a little room for today's cliffhanger puzzle. Oh, the haunting whirr-whirr-whirr of the cliffhanger puzzle. The cliffhanger puzzle is like if a genie let you wish for more wishes, except you only get one more wish, and it's a puzzle. And today's cliffhanger goes thusly. I'm going to read a sentence to you. Can you replace five parts of this sentence with five uses of the same one word while keeping the meaning of the sentence the same? So again, I'm going to read the sentence to you. I want you to replace five parts of it with the same word while keeping the meaning the same. And
你的牛排就免单了！但在开吃之前，确保给今天的悬念谜题留出一点空间。哦，悬念谜题那萦绕不去的嗡嗡声。悬念谜题就像是如果一个精灵允许你许愿更多的愿望，只是你只能再多许一个愿望，而且这个愿望是个谜题。今天的悬念谜题是这样的。我要给你读一个句子。你能用同一个单词的五次使用来替换这个句子的五个部分，同时保持句子的意思不变吗？所以再次说明，我要把这个句子读给你听。我需要你用同一个单词替换其中的五个部分，同时保持意思不变。那
that sentence is, after watching a concert and part of a tennis match on my TV, I put dishes on the table, then turned my clock back for daylight saving time. Again, I'll read you that sentence one more time. Yeah, slower. After... After watching a concert and part of a tennis match on my TV, I put dishes on the table, then turned my clock back for daylight saving time. So for next episode, can you replace five of the parts of that sentence with the same single word and keep the meaning of the sentence the same?
个句子是：看完一场音乐会和电视上的一场网球比赛的一部分后，我把盘子放在桌上，然后把时钟拨回以适应夏令时。再次说明，我再把那句子给你读一遍。慢一点。看完……看完一场音乐会和电视上的一场网球比赛的一部分后，我把盘子放在桌上，然后把时钟拨回以适应夏令时。所以对于下一集，你能用同一个单一单词替换该句子的五个部分，并保持句子意思不变吗？
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Very good. Well, the feds are here and this time they've got a warrant same. Yeah, yeah. Okay, very good. Well, the feds are here and this time they've got a warrant, so we better ring this episode to a close. But first, I'd like to thank Jeff Maxx for finding the quickest path to our hearts. And I'd like to thank Sean Hayes for taking a more roundabout route to the heart. Sure. I get it.
行。好。非常不错。联邦调查局的人来了，这次他们带着搜查令，所以我们最好把这一集节目收尾了。但首先，我要感谢杰夫·马克斯找到了通往我们内心的最快路径。我还要感谢肖恩·海斯选择了一条更曲折的通心之路。当然。我懂。
He's getting there. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Still on the road. Exactly. And I'd like to thank you, the listeners, for accepting these sound waves into your head right now. Until next time, this has been Smartless Presents Clueless, and I've been your host, Elliot Kalin, saying that by the power vested in me by the Universal Life Church and the state
他正在路上呢。对，对，对。还在路上。没错。我还要感谢你们，听众们，此刻让这些声波进入你们的大脑。直到下次，这里是《SmartLess Presents: Clueless》，我是你们的主持人埃利奥特·凯林。借由全灵教会和蒙大拿州赋予我的权力，我宣布你们现在和此刻坐在你们旁边的人结为夫妻。祝贺你们（Mazel Tov）！非常好。Clueless！
of Montana, I now pronounce you married to whoever you're sitting next to right now. Mazel Tov! Very good. Clueless! You have been listening to Smartless Presents Clueless, a Smartless Media production in association with SiriusXM. Your host is Elliot Kaelin, who also writes our scripts. Your constant contestant is Sean Hayes, Dreamer, Adventurer.
你收听的是由 Smartless Media 联合 SiriusXM 制作的节目《SmartLess Presents: Clueless》。你的主持人是埃利奥特·凯林，他同时也负责编写我们的剧本。你常驻的参赛选手是肖恩·海斯，梦想家、冒险家。
Your producer, editor, and engineer is Devon Torrey-Brindt, who is me. I also write all the music and sound effects. Assistant engineer, Kyle McGraw. Today's puzzles were written by Josh Richmond. Talent producer is Anne Harris, associate producer Maddie McCann, social media producer Tommy Galgano, executive producers are Elliot Kalin, Sean Hayes, Will Arnett, and Jason Bateman. Executive producers for Smartless Media are Richard Corson and Bernie Kaminsky. Remember to follow, subscribe, rate, and review the
你的制作人、剪辑师和音效师是德文·托里-布兰特，也就是我。我还负责创作所有的音乐和音效。助理音效师是凯尔·麦格劳。今天的谜题由乔什·里奇曼编写。艺人统筹是安·哈里斯，副制作人麦迪·麦肯，社交媒体制作人汤米·加尔加诺，执行制作人是埃利奥特·凯林、肖恩·海斯、威尔·阿奈特和杰森·贝特曼。Smartless Media 的执行制作人是理查德·科森和伯尼·卡明斯基。记得关注、订阅、评分和评论本
show. It really helps. That's all for now. We will see you again for more. Clueless. Clueless. Thank you to our partner, Monopoly, for supporting today's episode. Just like Clueless is a shorter, faster show from Smartless Media, Monopoly is introducing three new expansion packs that you add on to Classic Monopoly for fresh twists, faster gameplay, and a modern take on the game you love.
节目。这真的很有帮助。今天就到这里。我们下期节目再见。Clueless。Clueless。感谢我们的合作伙伴 Monopoly 对今天节目的支持。就像 Clueless 是来自 Smartless Media 的一档更短、节奏更快的节目一样，Monopoly 推出了三个全新的扩展包，你可以将它们添加到经典大富翁中，体验全新的转折、更快的游戏玩法，以及对你所爱游戏的现代诠释。
I'm talking about Monopoly. Look out for the all new buy everything, go to jail or free parking jackpot expansions to spice up your next game night. Pick your expansion and level up your game available now on Amazon. Monopoly is a trademark of Hasbro. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我说的是 Monopoly。留意全新的“买下一切”、“进监狱”或“免费停车大奖”扩展包，为你的下一个游戏之夜增添趣味。挑选你的扩展包并升级你的游戏，现已在亚马逊上架。Monopoly 是孩之宝的商标。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。